ZDF heute live schön dass ihr mit dabei
seid heute mal wieder zu einem Ukraine
Update es gibt aktuell keine
patsuation das stellte vor kurzem noch
mal der ukrainische Präsident selenski
klar beide Seiten verfolgen
augenscheinlich ihre Ziele innerhalb
dieses Krieges verzeichnen Gewinne wie
auch Verluste die Ukraine verstärkte
aktuell ihre armeepräsenz und
Militärtechnik am südlichen denipro Ufer
um rerson der weil konnten die vom
Westen gelieferten attackems Raketen
neue Erfolge erzielen so berichten
Berichten zufolge gibt es da z.B den
Treffer eines großen russischen
Munitionslagers in der von Russland
besetzten Region
siedovee und da sehen wir noch aktuelle
Bilder die vom ukrainischen Militär
publiziert wordurden die Russen auf der
anderen Seite fokussieren der weil
weiterhin die ostukrainische Stadt auf
dievka es wurde Personal aufgestockt vor
Ort es wurde Munition aufgestockt und so
schreiben russische Militärexperten
mittlerweile davon dass die Russen
weiter vorrücken und die Stadt sogar
umzingelt hätten wir wollen deshalb
heute bei ZDF heute live fragen wie ist
aktuell der Stand der Dinge im
ukrainekrieg wie groß ist die Abnutzung
beider Seiten wie entscheidend können
russlandsverluste im weiteren Krieg sein
und wollen zudem auch noch vusblicken
auf das neue Jahr und schauen welche
neue mögliche Phase nun in dem Krieg
kommen könnte dazu wollen wir sprechen
mit dem militärökonomen Markus KB von
der ETH Zürich und wir schalten auch
noch live in die Ukraine in Kiev steht
unser Reporter Dara hasassansad auch mit
ihm wollen wir sprechen und dazu gerne
wieder mit euren Fragen Meinungen und
Kommentaren die ihr uns schicken könnt
über die Kommentarspalten oder auch wiea
Mail an
zdfheute-live@zfde zunächst schalten wir
aber in die Schweiz dort sitzt unser
erster Gast für heute Markus Kolb der
militärökonom seit 2 3 lehrt er an der
ETH Zürich forscht unter anderem und
beschäftigt sich dort mit Handel und
Logistik im Krieg einen schönen guten
Namen zu Ihnen Herr Kolb hallo grüße Sie
Herr Kolb vor einem Monat befand sich
der Krieg nach ihren Beobachtungen so
haben sie das bei uns hier in der
Sendung gesagt in einer
abnutzungsphase wo steht er
heute in der abnutzungsphase sind wir
immer noch die Russen sind gerade dabei
die Abnutzung tatkräftig zu
beschleunigen indem sie ihre Fahrzeuge
bei aftievka geradezu reihweise ins
ukrainische Feuer schicken ähm aber es
es gilt eigentlich immer noch
das was ich letztes Mal gesagt habe man
darf sich im Moment keine großen
mechanisierten Durchbrüche erwarten äh
das liegt sowohl an neuen
technologischen Entwicklungen die wir im
Moment auf dem Schlachtfeld sehen da
sage ich dann später noch was dazu ähm
als auch eben an dem an dem Problem dass
Russland nach wie vor die Initiative
verloren hat versucht sie zurück zu
gewinnen dabei auch enorme Verluste
bereit ist in Kauf zu nehmen
aber nicht durchkommt das heißt also die
Frage ist hier eigentlich jeden Tag wer
zwingt hier wen in die Abnutzung und wer
kann letztlich mit seinem Industrie und
technologiepotenzial länger durchhalten
Stichwort technologiepotential Drohnen
bleiben ja
augenscheinlich wenn man so die Berichte
sich durchliest ein sehr prägendes
Element in diesem Krieg die Ukraine
setzt seit September auf sogenannte FPV
also
view kamikaz Drohnen sie haben zuletzt
remote Einsätze südlich des denpro bei
krinki beobachtet erzählen sie uns genau
wie nutzt die Ukraine solche
drohentechnik genau
ein genau jetzt sehen wir gerade die
Karte von
krinki muss dazu wie immer etwas
ausholen diese diese Operation hier am
südlichenprufer die läuft schon länger
also schon mindestens seit dem Sommer
und wir haben immer wieder so Boote von
ukrainischen Spezialkräften gesehen die
versucht haben äh überzusetzen und dort
eine lokale Präsenz zu etablieren ähm
ich habe das lange Zeit zwar beobachtet
aber nicht so wirklich ernst genommen
weil ich gesagt habe okay die die
schauen mal die testen mal so ein
bisschen was da geht und und fahren dann
wieder ab ähm jetzt hat sich aber über
die letzten Wochen ein anderes Bild
ergeben nämlich erstens dass die sich
relativ erfolgreich halten können an
diesem Ufer obwohl die Russen da drüben
konventionell absolut überlegen stehen
und zweitens ähm dass sie mit einer
sozusagen einer Fernsteuerung operieren
das heißt ähm das ist kein schweres
Material der Ukraine das dort steht es
sind auch nicht unbedingt viele
Kombattanten ich würde sagen vielleicht
Z bis 300 in diesem Raum krinky maximal
aber sie benutzen ähm so ziemlich alles
an Drohnen und raketenartillerie was sie
haben auf ihrem Ufer des des nipro um
dort hinüber zu schießen und sehr
erfolgreich haben sich eben first person
view drones erwiesen dann das war ein
ein Thema über das wir noch eben so März
April diesen Jahres kaum gesprochen
haben die wurden auch kaum eingesetzt an
der Front haben mittlerweile aber eine
sehr große Bedeutung erlangt ähm einfach
weil sie
nicht nur die die artilleristischen
Mittel der Russen sehr gut aufklären
können sondern sie auch gleich zerstören
können und das verändert natürlich die
Taktik
wie sie dort kämpfen also Artillerie
herauszunehmen ist normalerweise nicht
so einfach normalerweise würden sie
Counter battery fire nehmen das heißt
also sie müssen ihre e Artillerie die
gegnerische Artillerie sehr genau
treffen das ist schwierig aber mit
drohen wird das sehr viel leichter und
das überraschende ist eigentlich dass
die Russen bisher nicht in der Lage sind
diese kleinen ukrainischen Verbände die
da operieren jetzt sehen wir gerade hier
so ein pa dronenbilder diese wieder
zurückzuwerfen also aufs andere Ufer des
des nipron das das hat mich ehrlich
gesagt überrascht
weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
dass die Russen wirklich damit gerechnet
haben auf diese Art und Weise
konfrontiert zu werden
ähm und Sie können sich ja als Zuschauer
mal ähm anschauen wie wie der größere
Raum dort aussieht also wenn sie von
armiansk der Nordspitze der Krim eine
Linie ziehen in Richtung nordnordwest
bis norv kachowka äh dann haben sie in
ungefähr den gesamten Raum der
südwestfronte dort stehen sieben
russische Brigaden die werden aber nur
versorgt über zwei
hauptversorgungsachsen die Autobahnen
M14 und M17 und da zeigt sich ein
weiterer äh Vorteil der äh der PV drones
nämlich sobald Sie diese Straßen
kontrollieren das heißt also sobald sie
die sehen und und alle fahrenden Mittel
dort sofort beschießen können dann
kontrollieren Sie auch die Versorgung da
sind wir wieder beim alten
Ansatz den die Ukraine eigentlich immer
gehabt hat in diesem Krieg nämlich die
versorgungsachsen zu unterbinden und
wenn ihr das gelingen sollte dann wäre
das ein großer Fortschritt an der
südwestlichen Front jetzt muss man aber
auch ein bisschen kaltes Wasser da da
drauf Gießen also es gibt jetzt manche
die sprechen schon von Brückenkopf und
und nipro Überquerung und und so weiter
man muss sich dann
auch noch mal im Klaren sein der der
Dnipro ist dort also selbst an der
engsten Stelle bei W das ist etwas
westlich von nor kachovke
selbst dort ist er ungefähr 300 m breit
das heißt sie können also nicht ohne
weiteres ein ein Flussübergang machen
wenn sie nicht totale Artillerie
Überlegenheit haben und und close Air
Support und so weiter also das das
glaube ich nicht aber ähm es es ist doch
ein eindrückliches Zeichen ähm wie wie
stark Sie hier mit mit klein billigsten
Mitteln also so eine FPV Drone die
besseren die Kosten so zwischen 700 und
1000 USDollar pro Stück wie sie damit
doch Wirkung erzielen gegen viel größere
und gepanzerte Systeme die Ukraine
spricht im Moment so von ihrem Projekt
army of drones also z sagen wir wir
gehen technologisch eigentlich ein
völlig anderen Weg nämlich in Richtung
Dezentralisierung der Artillerie also
dass wir quasi sagen wir wir nehmen
nicht wenige große Artilleriegeschütze
sondern wir schicken viele viele kleine
Drohnen los und nehmen damit Stück für
Stück die russischen Systeme heraus mm
wir bekommen schon zahlreiche erste
Zuschauerfragen gerade wo wir jetzt über
Material sprechen über Waffen die da zum
Einsatz kommen haben wir die Frage
gestellt bekommen auf Youtube wie gut
bzw schlecht ist die Ukraine mit ihren
Partnern im Vergleich zu Russland
aufgestellt beim Thema Waffenproduktion
kann sich die Ukraine einen lang eine
lange Materialschlacht
leisten also da muss man muss man zwei
Dinge sehen das das eine ist worüber wir
immer sprechen nämlich die westliche
Unterstützung äh die muss natürlich
weitergehen also das das nehme ich bei
meinen Analysen natürlich immer implizit
an ähm der der Fluss der westlichen
Waffen in die Ukraine der ist
alternativlos und das bezieht sich nicht
nur auf die jetzigen Systeme sondern
auch auf zukünftige Systeme die
eigentlich schon längst da sein müssten
ich sage ja immer der fatale Fehler des
Westens war dass man den Russen Zeit
gegeben hat sich einzugraben also die
surwikin Linie äh zu bauen hätte man ihr
früher schon schwere Mittel
raketenartillerie und so weiter gegeben
dann wären wir jetzt nicht in dieser in
dieser Kriegslage das ist das eine das
andere ist aber auch der Aufbau einer
eigenständigen ukrainischen
Rüstungsindustrie der ebenfalls
voranschreitet das heißt man man darf
sich die Ukraine also langfristig nicht
nicht so als als Transferempfänger
vorstellen sondern man muss ich im klar
sein noch zu sowjetischen Zeiten war ein
großer Teil der sowjetischen
Rüstungsindustrie in der Ukraine also
hakif hat bis heute hervorragenden Ruf
für Mathematik inieurs Wissenschaften da
saßen früher die rüstungsingenieure und
die rüstungswissenschaftler die wurden
da auf ausgebildet
in der Gegend von Lugansk standen früher
die antonof Flugzeugwerke und ir ein
Großteil der sowjetischen
Rüstungsindustrie z.B Motoren gebaut
haben für Hubschrauber und für Flugzeuge
also es ist nicht so dass die dass die
Ukraine quasi kein technologisches
Wissen hätte sondern im Gegenteil sie
ist jetzt eigentlich dabei das wieder
aufzubauen muss man aber noch was
drittes sehen nämlich die Russen sind
natürlich auch nicht ganz dumm und fähig
was ihre eigene Industrie angeht und
entwickeln sich natürlich auch laufend
weiter und wenn wir jetzt über das Thema
drohen sprechen haben die Russen gerade
eine Innovation eingeführt bei ihrer
leutering
Munition also bei der bei der landset
Drohne die von den sal Werken
hergestellt wird und die hat
normalerweise nur eine Range eine
Reichweite von 40 km jetzt haben wir
aber Videos bestätigte Videos gesehen
von Abschüssen in der Ukraine die
nahelen dass sie mittlerweile 70 bis 90
km Reichweite hat und die Ukraine hat
bisher überend Switchblade aus aus
Großbritannien die hat 40 km Reichweite
das heißt das ist jetzt eigentlich die
nächste Herausforderung für die Ukraine
das heißt sie müsste jetzt eigentlich
statt switchplade 300 wie jetzt
switchplade 600 bekommen die hat
ebenfalls bis 90 km operative Reichweite
und Sie sehen dass das ist was ich
meinte mit mit Technologie also man man
darf nicht so stehen bleiben und sagen
wie viel Stück äh von irgendwas bekommst
du sondern man muss auch ähm schauen
dass man mindestens auf dem gleichen
technologieniveau ist wie der Gegner
wenn nicht sogar drüber und ähm das ist
auch das was salusni gemeint hat ähm in
in seinem Artikel ähm dass man eben
technologische Überlegenheit braucht äh
wenn man diesen Krieg letztlich gewinnen
mhm über den Artikel reden wir später
noch ähm da gucken wir noch mal ganz
genauer drauf weil der hat ja auch die
Nachrichtenlage ein bisschen geprägt in
den letzten Tagen dazu später wir wollen
jetzt erstmal den aktuellen Blick auf
den Stand der Dinge richten und in
verschiedene Regionen schauen und Sie
haben gerade Technologien und
Reichweiten angesprochen Herr Kolb da
lohnt sich dann auch der Blick
in die Südukraine ans Asowsche Meer nach
siedove wir haben es eingangs schon
gesagt da gab es scheinbar so berichten
das ukrainische Medien einen Erfolg dass
man mit den sogenannten attackems
Raketen ein großes russisches Waffen
Munitionsdepot angegriffen hat und
scheinbar auch abgeschossen hat
zumindest gibt's aktuelle Bilder davon
die belegen dass es da große Flammen und
Feuerbälle gab ist das die aktuelle
Taktik der Ukraine jetzt mit westlichen
Waffen speziell solche Ziele
anzugreifen ja das das das war sie
eigentlich schon lange das Problem war
einfach dass dass die beiden
Administrationen sich nicht dazu
durchringen konnte diese Waffen zu
liefern das war übrigens der
US-Präsident der letztlich dann das äh
das Okay gegeben hat also es es war in
Teilen der beiden Administration bis zum
Schluss umstritten ob man die Ukraine
wirklich damit damit ausstatten sollte
ich ich halte diese Überlegung für
völlig hirnrüssig weil
sie brauchen natürlich Lang Lang
Reichweiten raketenartillerie
um die russische Front in der Tiefe zu
zerstören insbesondere auf der Krim und
das Interessante beed ist jetzt
vielleicht können wir die die Karte kurz
eingeblendet sehen von siadove das
Interessante ist wenn Sie einen Radius
ziehen um diesen Ort von siadove ähm
jetzt sehen wir es gerade genau und sie
sie können das ja zu Hause auf auf der
Karte mal nachvollziehen wenn Sie wollen
und sie sie ziehen ziehen sie mal ein
Radius von 150 km ums hieredowe
und da dann merken sie dann sind sie
knapp an der frontgrenze das heißt also
dieser dieser ziemlich spektakuläre
Abschluss von diesem Munitionsdepot der
wäre mit haimas die ja maximal 80 km
Reichweite haben oder mit jeder anderen
Form von Artillerie die die Ukraine hat
gar nicht möglich und das da merken Sie
was ich meine mit in der Tiefe und es
gibt nur zwei Systeme
mit denen sie das machen können das eine
ist attackems was die Ukraine ja
mittlerweile hat und das andere ist ein
Waffensystem das in Zukunft kommen wird
sogenannte glsdb ground Launch small
diameter bomb
das ist schon angekündigt von Boeing SAB
das kommt diesen herbstwinter also
vermutlich so in vier Wochen müssen wir
das im Einsatzraum sehen
und da ist noch der Vorteil das hat
ähnliche Range wie die jetzigen tackams
M39 Raketen also ungefähr 150 km aber es
gibt viel mehr davon also von attackams
gibt's derzeit noch einige hundert äh
auf der Welt man muss ja denken dass das
alles sehr alte Waffensysteme sind von
gasdb gibt's ungefähr 17 000 die bis
heute produziert worden und sie sehen
dass das ist so eine der technologischen
Entwicklungen die in die wir jetzt
reingehen äh in den Winter in diesem
Krieg also sprich wir werden weniger
mechanisierte Operationen sehen sondern
viel stärker artillerieoperationen eben
in auf kürzere Distanz mit Drohnen und
auf längere Distanz äh mit
raketenartillerie mm da stellt sich dann
auch noch die Anschlussfrage wie groß
dieser Verlust jetzt ist wenn so ein
Munitionsdepot getroffen wurde für die
russische Seite und das interessiert
auch unsere Zuschauer die fragen in
welchem Zusammenhang stehen die
russischen Verluste mit der Lieferung
von westlicher Munition in ausreichender
Menge für die Ukraine
mm also ich glaube für für SED ist es
jetzt weniger ein Thema weil der Vorteil
dieser dieser Langstrecken
raketenartillerie ist einfach wenn Sie
sie ein Ziel damit treffen dann
erreichen sie große Zerstörungswirkung
aber auf einem relativ kleinen Raum das
heißt
sowas würden Sie machen wenn Sie
sogenanntes highvue target haben also
z.B ein Kommandozentrum
oder eine Ansammlung von Schiffen was
wir ja auch jetzt gesehen haben bei den
Schlägen z.B gegen gegen Kersch oder
gegen
Sevastopol oder wenn Sie wenn Sie eine
Ansammlung von beweglichen Zielen haben
wie z.B ähm der Flugplatz in berdansk wo
der erste Einsatz der der erteigens
erfolgt ist und wo sie viele russische
Hubschrauber zerstören könnten
die kontinuierliche Munitionsversorgung
die ist eher ein Thema für die
klassische Artillerie das heißt also
dass sie genügend Geschosse haben
von von den üblichen NATO Kalibern die
sie eben aus der westlichen Artillerie
verschießen und wir müssen uns ja immer
im Plan sein wir reden da über eine
Schussfrequenz von ungefähr 5000 pro Tag
äh bei der Ukraine also 5000
Artilleriegranaten pro Tag ähm das
können sie ja mal hochrechnen auf den
Jahresbedarf und da ist es natürlich
wichtig dass da die industriekapazität
bereit steht um da weiterzuliefern und
man muss sagen 5000 pro Tag das ist noch
nicht mal viel die Russen waren im
Sommer 22 bei 50.000 pro Tag
und sind jetzt ebenfalls aufgrund ihrer
ihrer Industrie
shortages also ihrer ihrer
Produktionsmenge ähm auf etwa 9000 pro
Tag äh herunter und auch da deswegen
habe ich ja vorhin gesagt ähm es ist
eine Frage des lang fristigen
industriepotenzials W diesen Krieg dann
wollen wir noch zuletzt auf die Region
avdka in den Osten schauen Herr KB das
ist seit einigen Wochen Zentrum des
Krieges und auch in dieser Woche hat der
Chef der ukrainischen Streitkräfte das
in den Medien bestätigt die Russen
hätten da noch mal 40.000 Mann
zusätzlich in die Region gebracht
aufgerüstet mit Munition aller Kaliber
ein russischer militärblogger schreibt
dass die Stadt umkreist ist eingezingelt
ist und das interessiert auch unsere
Zuschauer Helmut rosten fragt auf
Youtube wie waren die russischen
Streitkräfte in der Lage für afdka so
eine gewaltige Menge an schützen und
Kampfpanzern zusammenzuziehen sind die
alle neu aus Russland
gekommen ja das ist eine sehr gute Frage
die die dürfen Sie direkt weiterreichen
an den ukrainischen Geheimdienst
also eigentlich dürfte ihnen sowas nicht
passieren ne dass dass der Gegner im im
Hinterland dass sie ja relativ nah bei
sich haben und und relativ gut
beobachten können solche Reserven
zusammenziehen kann erstens und zweitens
dann einfach da losbricht ähm ohne ohne
dass sie das äh wirklich vorausgesehen
haben also die Ukraine hat natürlich
sofort Verstärkungen ähm in den Raum
hinein verlegt und konnte den Angriff
auch ziemlich erfolgreich aufhalten das
lag aber nicht so sehr an der
Abwehrleistung der Ukraine sondern viel
mehr an der an der Dummheit der Russen
äh die genau so vorgegangen sind wie wir
es in diesem Raum übrigens also gerade
auch bei auf die jefka äh im Januar
Februar diesen Jahres gesehen haben
vielleicht erinnern sich manche
Zuschauer es gab damals ebenfalls große
mechanisierte Angriffe der Russen bei
vuleda bei mariinkke und eben auch bei
aftijivka jetzt muss man wissen AF
diejivka ist ein ein sehr sehr stark
befestigter Punkt der Front schon seit
2015 also sie können sich vorstellen das
ist ein komplett professionell
ausgebautes System in Beton ausgegossen
mit mit Tunneln mit verbundenen
Unterständen also das das ist eine
wirkliche Festung sowohl über als auch
unter der Erde und da rein zukommen ähm
das ist sehr sehr schwierig und dazu
kommt halt noch dass die Art und Weise
wie die Russen vorgegangen sind wirklich
so das so das dümmste ist was sie machen
können ja also wie im Januar Februar
lass uns mit einer Kolonne über offenes
Feld fahren ja da liegen zwar ein paar
Minen aber da wird schon nichts
passieren und ach selbst wenn dann geht
das Material halt drauf aber wir gehen
dann schon wir kommen schon durch am
Ende ich weiß nicht was die was die
lokalen Kommandeure oder oder gerasimow
der das ja letztlich zu verantworten hat
was die sich dabei denken aber sind
macht das Ganze nicht wenn wir die Karte
noch mal kurz einblenden könnten
da kann ich Ihnen kurz erzählen was was
eigentlich die Idee war dieses
russischen Vorstoßes sie sehen auf die
hiivka ist eine Tasche die sich tief
erstreckt in die in die Front und wenn
Sie jetzt die die beiden Spitzen da
nehmen die sie die sie am linken und am
oberen Bildrand sehen und sie sie
zeichnen da so eine geistige Linie von
Spitze zu Spitze und dann sehen Sie wenn
es Ihnen also gelingt durch einen
Zangenangriff von Süden und von Norden
diese Tasche einzuschließen dann hätten
sie quasi einen der stärksten
Ankerpunkte der ukrainischen Ostfront
herausgenommen das war eigentlich die
Idee und da muss ich sagen also beim
beim Süden mache ich mir überhaupt keine
Sorgen da ist also alles gescheitert was
die Russen hineingeworfen haben
geländegewinnen können sie dort in
Metern messen
beim Nord im Norden sind sie etwas
weiter vorangekommen also diese gerade
Linie die sie da oben sehen am oberen
Bildrand das ist eine Eisenbahnlinie bis
dahin sind die Russen vorgestoßen das
sind also einige 100 Meter
Geländegewinne
unter enormen Opfern es ist personell
ungefähr eine halbe Brigade drauf
gegangen also etwa 4000 Mann und allein
im Raum auf dieivkat etwa 200 Fahrzeuge
von denen wir Geolokalisierung haben
oder Bildnachweis also die die bestätigt
drauf gegangen sind
das ist aber nur auf die hivka jetzt
müssen sie aber denken die Russen haben
es auch gleichzeitig an anderen Punkten
versucht also auch in Minka auch in im
Raum Bach auch in kupjansk ähm und auch
in in wuleda und ähm der der Plan war
vermutlich so beides zu schaffen also
einerseits die ukrainische Abwehr so ein
bisschen zu ermüden oder zu fixieren äh
s dass die Ukraine nicht weiß wo die
jetzt angreifen und das andere eben die
Tasche von AF dieivka hier zuzumachen
und
einzukapseln muss ich ehrlich sagen also
fail äh bei bei keiner Operation haben
sie irgendeinen Vorteil erreicht außer
minimale Geländegewinne äh unter unter
wirklich extremen Opfern und ich glaube
nicht dass sie das noch sehr lange
durchhalten können wir sind bei
russischen panzerverlusten jetzt bei
ungefähr 2400 spannend wird's wenn wir
bei 3000 sind weil das ist die
Konsensschätzung des schwedischen foi
und des britischen iiss dann sind die
einsatzfähigen Reserven aufgebraucht und
ab dann müssten sie eigentlich nur noch
umstellen auf ältere Systeme und auf
instandhaltungssysteme damit müsste
eigentlich ein stärkerer Rückschritt der
der frontaktivitäten verbunden sein
aktueller ein Zungen mit geographischen
Erläuterungen von Markus Kolb von der
ETH Zürich vielen Dank bis hierhin Herr
Kolb wir reden gleich noch weiter
blicken da noch voraus wollen jetzt aber
mal kurz in die Ukraine schalten in Kiev
steht unser Reporter Dara Hassan Sade
Dara einen schönen guten Abend zu dir du
hast in den letzten Tagen zum Thema
Handel in der Ukraine recherchiert du
warst drehen vor Ort hast mit einem
Landwirt gesprochen und kannst
bilanzieren der Handel läuft in der
Ukraine der seekorridor funktioniert und
die Russen das liest man aus aktuellen
Bericht en die reagieren mit Angriffen
auf Frachter
hatte das man hatte das ja bislang
eigentlich vermieden also jetzt scheint
es da auch ein strategischen Wandel zu
geben ja also seitdem die Russen aus dem
getreideabkommen ausgestiegen sind haben
sie 160 Luftangriffe auf die
hafenstrukturen im Süden auf die
hochseefahhäfen geflogen sie haben auch
den kleineren Hafen in Ismael ganz
massiv beschossen der direkt an der
Grenze zu Rumänien liegt da wo auch ähm
Trümmerteile ähm auf rumänisches Gebiet
geflogen sind von dort gehen nur
kleinere Schiffe raus der äh der
Landwirt mit dem ich ä gesprochen habe
blickte eigentlich wieder ganz gut in
die Zukunft und zwar sagte er dass er
für dieses Jahr mit einer schwarzen mit
einer guten schwarzen Null rechnet die
Preise seien wieder angestiegen und das
hängt auch damit zusammen dass die
großen hochseehäfen wieder funktionieren
das Fr Frachter Einlaufen in großen
Mengen Getreide abtransportieren und
genau das war ja das Ziel der russischen
Luftangriffe das zu verhindern und
deswegen sehe ich in diesem gestrigen
Angriff auf den Frachter der unter
liberärischer Flagge gefahren ist eine
gewisse Steigerung
m und
das Ziel wird wohl sein Räder
einzuschüchtern das haben Sie auch schon
im Vorfeld mit Drogen mit Angriffen auf
hoher See auf Frachter die sich in dem
Gebiet bewegen getan und jetzt ist ein
anderes Zeichen es ist nämlich eine
antischiffsrakete gewesen mit 600 kg
Sprengstoff die von
einem kampfchet der der der Russen
abgeschossen wurde ganz gezielt auf
diesen Frachter der schon in der
Einfahrt nach Odessa war also nicht auf
der auf dem offenen See und das ist ein
Zeichen dass diese dieser seekorridor
den die Ukraine am Anfang auch mit so
einem international wurde es so ein
bisschen belächelt die Zuversicht die
auch vor allem
selenski ausgestrahlt hat weil das
Risiko eines Frachters in ein
Kriegsgebiet reinzufahren ist ja immer
auch der Totalverlust des Schiffes der
Menschen und auch der Ladung und
trotzdem
scheint es gelungen zu sein mhm jetzt
steht der nächste Winter in den
stlöchern in der Ukraine Dara und der
ukrainische staabschef und
Oberbefehlshaber Sal sch hat sich in der
letzten Woche hat so ein bisschen seinen
Unmut Luft gemacht kann man sagen er hat
in der britischen Wochenzeitung The
Economist ein Interview gegeben hat
da seine Verwunderung ausgedrückt dass
die Russen mit ihrer Taktik doch länger
durchhalten als dass
das ukrainische Militär ursprünglich
vermutet hatte er nennt auch ähm so ein
bisschen Unmut in Sachen Waffenlieferung
argumentiert ganz fachlich militärisch
was die Ukraine für das nächste Jahr
braucht er nennt militärische Prios
versprüht aber sehr wenig Euphorie das
hat sie ens jetzt nicht unbedingt gut
geschmeckt dass sich der Kollege da so
einmischt gibt das da jetzt aktuell
gerade ein Zerwürfnis zwischen den
beiden ich würde da nicht von einem
persönlichen zerwirfnis sprechen sondern
das liegt eher in den Funktionen die die
beiden inner haben saluschni als
Oberbefehlshaber ist verantwortlich für
die militärische Taktik und natürlich
auch dafür wie weiter vorgegangen wird
mit dem Material was er zur Verfügung
hat er hat in dem Interview eigentlich
ähm das Offensichtliche ausgesprochen er
hat gesagt es gibt einen technologischen
Gleichstand und man könne nicht mit
einem schönen großen erfolgreichen
Durchbruch rechnen ähm damit hat er
natürlich
darauf angespielt dass ihm die Waffen
fehlen das hatte er auch schon zu Beginn
der Großoffensive im Süden gesagt ganz
deutlich hat er gesagt dass kein
natogeneral eine solche Großoffensive
mit den Waffenarsenal beginnen würde was
er zur Verfügung hat er wusste sehr wohl
dass er die Angriffe nicht im Verbund
fliegen führen kann weil er nämlich
keine kampfchatz hatte und nur die
Leoparden und gepaden wusste auch dass
er die mene die minräum räumepanzer
nicht ausreichen und hat dann die Taktik
umgestellt nachdem am am Anfang glaube
ich er auf einen kurzen
überraschungs Effekt setzte und viele
Leoparden am Anfang mal zum Einsatz
kamen verantwortlich für die Ausrüstung
des Militärs in der Ukraine ist wie in
jedem Land das stad der Stad das
stadsoberhaupt selenski und selenski ist
in einer sehr schwierigen Position zum
einen neigt sich das Budget was die
Amerikaner an Ukraine Hilfe schon
aufgesetzt haben und ein neues ist noch
lange nicht in Gesicht da es im Kongress
durch die Republikaner zu keiner
Verabschiedung kommt hinzu kommt noch
dass die Deutschland als größer als Land
mit großer Rüstungs Industrie zögert das
Kanzleramt war von Anfang an immer
eigentlich zu wenig und zu spät dabei
wenn man sich und das wird vor allem
saluschni wissen
schon viel früher
mit Leoparden ausgestattet gewesen weren
dann werf diese große Ost
Offensive
Richtung lohansk viel weiter gegangen
als sie dann tatsächlich gekommen ist da
fehlt also auch schon das Material und
selenski hat seine größte Waffe im
Moment nicht die Öffentlichkeit er kann
kein Druck aufbauen die
Weltöffentlichkeit blickt nach Israel
ähm Ukraine findet in den in den Medien
immer weniger stad und von daher kann
auch innenpolitisch keine größeren
Diskussionen entstehen und jetzt z.B in
der Kanzler
im Kanzleramt ist man glaube ich schon
sehr froh dass die taurusdebatte ob man
sie jetzt liefern müsse oder nicht
extrem abgeäppt ist unter diesem
medialen Fokus der im Moment auf Israel
liegt ich möchte dir gerne noch zum
Abschluss darer eine Frage von von
unseren Zuschauern weiterleiten ähm die
Fragen wie ist die Stimmung in der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung zeigt sich da
aktuell eine Kriegsmüdigkeit bzw kommt
der Wunsch auch vielleicht doch mit
Russland zu verhandeln kannst du dazu
was
sagen ja ja und ja das Land ist
kriegsmüde es ist auch ganz
selbstverständlich wenn man sich die
Länge der Front anguckt die die
Heftigkeit der ankämp der Angriffe
allein was
eben geschildert W de über die Angriffe
auf adivka das bedeutet im Umkehrschluss
dass von dort immer wieder Nachrichten
kommen in die Familien zu Freunden
Schulfreunden die die gefallen sind und
das geht mitten in die Gesellschaft rein
kriegsmüigkeit ist hier aber kein
Synonym für einen Abbruch der Motivation
man weiß in der Ukraine was
ein Staat bedeutet der von Russland
abhängig ist man wird auf alle frei
verzichten müssen für die man bisher
gekämpft hat für die man die höchsten
Opfer gebracht hat und man weiß auch
wenn man sich dieser Kriegsmüdigkeit
hingeben würde dass dann auch das Land
im die Teile des Landes im Gefahr Gefahr
sind die man jetzt hält die Ukraine ist
ja im Moment scheitert ja bei dem
Versuch zurück zu erobern aber sie ist
ja eigentlich weit davon entfernt große
weitere Gebiete zu verlieren oder so wie
es am Anfang letzten Jahres war dass es
droht dass große Armeen von der
russischen Seite tief ins Land
eindringen können die Stimmung hier ist
also natürlich von mütigkeit und
Erschöpfung geprägt aber auch von
absolutem durchhaltewien ich habe jetzt
Leute getroffen die natürlich sich
Sorgen dass sie die nächsten sein
könnten die mobilisiert werden
die die Leute die wirklich militärische
Erfahrung haben und auch bereit sind zu
kämpfen die haben sich schon freiwi
gemeldet die sind schon unter den
anderthalb Millionen Soldaten wer jetzt
bei einer nächsten
mobilisierungs Welle Kandidat werden
wird sind die die eigentlich vom
Charakter her vom Glauben her die
eigentlich nicht zum Kämpfen geboren
wurden sage ich jetzt einfach mal so und
umgekehrt haben sich jetzt auch immer
mehr Frauen gemeldet freiwillig um
Lücken zu füllen die auftreten können
Einschätzungen live aus Kier von dar s
Dara vielen Dank an Dich ja wir haben
das Thema gerade schon
angerissen der ukrainische
oberbefehlshauber Valeri salusni hat
diese Woche
Schlagzeilen für Schlagzeilen gesorgt
mit militärischen Fakten im Hinblick auf
das kommende Jahr wenn der Krieg
möglicherweise in eine neue Phase
eintreten könnte wir schauen noch einmal
kurz auf das was er gegenüber der
britischen
wochenzeitschriftconomist gesagt
hat ein Stellungskrieg ist ein
langwieriger Krieg der enorme Risiken
für die Streitkräfte und den
ukrainischen Staat BGT wenn die Ukraine
dieser Falle entkommen will brauchen wir
all diese Dinge Luftüberlegenheit stark
verbesserte Fähigkeiten zur
elektronischen Kriegsführung und zur
artillerieaufklärung neue Technologie
zur minensprengung und die Fähigkeit
mehr Reservisten zu mobilisieren und
auszubilden tja soweit ein Zitat aus dem
Interview damit schalten wir noch einmal
zum militärökonom Markus Kolb Herr Kolb
das waren klare Worte also
Luftüberlegenheit sei wichtig
verbesserte elektronische Kriegsführung
und artillerieaufklärung aber vor allem
die ersten beiden Punkte sind ja
perspektivisch für den Krieg interessant
wird Militärtechnik künftig diesen Krieg
prägen ja absolut und es es freut mich
sehr dass sie diese Stelle zitieren weil
der Artikel von Sal ist im Westen häufig
so als ein bisschen als defetistisch
verstanden worden oder so als
Eingeständnis wir S Szen hier im Pad und
kommen nicht raus und dann dann kam
natürlich sofort wieder die
kremmelpapageien und und schreien nach
demem was sie Verhandlungen nennen also
nach dem Motto genau wie ihr
Korrespondent gesagt hat gebt doch
einfach auf ne und und wie ihr dann
künftig lebt ist nicht unsere Sache
hauptsache wir machen wieder
wohlstandspazifismus aber so kann man
keinen Krieg gewinnen und genau das ist
der Punkt
Russland wird diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen aber die Frage ist kann ihn die
Ukraine gewinnen ja also das was man in
Amerika als finish the job
diskutiert genau das ist die Frage und
ähm das das Kriegsziel der Ukraine ist
ja klar die Wiederherstellung ihrer
Staatlichkeit in den Grenzen von 191 ähm
aber genau das müsste eigentlich auch
das Kriegsziel äh der äh derjenigen sein
die die Ukraine unterstützen weil alles
andere ist eine Belohnung der russischen
Aggression also ist der Gedanke
folgerichtig was braucht die Ukraine
damit sie die russische Aggression
zurückwerfen kann das heißt also die
Russen zwingen diesen ukrainischen
staatsraum inklusive der Krim natürlich
zu verlassen und das schaffen sie nur
indem sie technologische Überlegenheit
haben und ähm die umfasst nun
verschiedene Bereiche die die solu hier
skizziert hat äh sie umfasst
insbesondere luftkampffähigkeit oder
Luftüberlegenheit das werden wir ab dem
nächsten Frühling sehen wenn dann die
westlichen F16 Kampfflugzeuge in den
Kampfraum Eingreifen werden die ersten
sind schon da aber bis der Training
Logistik und so weiter abgeschlossen ist
wird das ab heute vielleicht noch se
Monate dauern das zweite ist da da wo
die Russen relativ gut sind ist
elektronische Kriegführung und
Aufklärung mit Drohnen also die landzeit
operieren normalerweise in Verbindung
mit beobachtungsdrohnen und die Russen
sind sind ziemlich gut darin in dieser
Operation
was den Ukrainer bisher noch nicht so
wirklich gelungen ist ist eine
flächendeckende elektronische
gegenkriegführung das heißt also ein ein
flächendeckendes sperrnetz zu errichten
elektronisches spernetz dass die Drohnen
einfach abstürzen lässt
oder dass dass ihn die Kommunikation
abschneidet ähm da müssten sie dringend
auf ein neues technologieniveau kommen
wenn sie eben selber wieder in die in
die Offensive gehen wollen und das
dritte ist was ich schon erwähnt habe
also die die massive Ausstattung der
Ukraine mit Drohnen das was die Ukrainer
army of drones nennen wir müssen uns ja
im Klaren sein wir wir haben uns im
Westen manchmal aufgeregt in manchen
Ländern ob wir jetzt 20 unbewaffnete
beobachtungsdrohen beschaffen sollen ach
Gott ist das aggressiv sie müssen sich
im kan sein Drohnen sind in diesem Krieg
ein verschleißmittel ähm eine Drohne
hält im Durchschnitt zwei bis drei Tage
dann geht sie verloren oder wird
abgeschossen oder wie auch immer das
heißt wir reden hier über 10tausende
wenn nicht über Millionen von drohen
also ganze drohenschwärme äh die dann
über ein stellungsgebiet ausschwärmen
und sämtliche schweren Mittel die sie
erkennen sofort rausnehmen das ist eine
Dimension der der Kriegführung auch der
der indirekten Artillerie die wir bisher
noch in keinem konventionellen Krieg
gesehen haben das ist eine der
wesentlichen technologischen
Entwicklungen ähm die dieser Krieg
durchmacht deswegen sind klassische
Militärs meistens auch ein bisschen
hilflos wenn sie den Krieg beurteilen
wollen weil die gucken halt auf die
Geländekarte und auf Rot versus blau und
zeichnen ihre Pfeilchen ein ähm aber
sehen nicht die technologische
Komponente die die dieser Krieg äh mit
sich bringt also insofern
so so muss man solusion eigentlich
verstehen also nach dem Motto give us
what we need to finish the job und und
genau in in der in der Richtung macht es
auch Sinn also der Artikel ist ist kein
irgendwie kein kein deffetistisches
Stück oder auch kein kein Streit mit
selenski sondern er er spricht halt
unangenehme Wahrheiten an äh die man im
Westen nicht so gerne hören will ne es
ist es macht ein Unterschied ob man
sagen will die Ukraine darf nicht
verlieren äh oder ob man sagt die
russische Aggression muss zurückgewiesen
werden das haben noch nicht alle
verstanden noch nicht alle Politiker ja
jetzt schauen gerade sie ja gerne auf
Zahlen und argumentieren damit haben uns
auch schon ein paar Sachen mal
vorgerechnet in früheren Sendungen unter
anderem äh hatten sie auch mal von der
abnutzungsrate des russischen Militärs
was argumentiert und vor einem guten
halben Jahr die These hier gesetzt äh
dass Putins Niederlage im Oktober diesen
Jahres zu erwarten sei jetzt haben wir
mittlerweile November der Krieg läuft
weiter und auch unsere User die die
Sendung damals gesehen haben haben auch
schon gefragt was ist passiert Herr Kolb
ja also ich ich sag an sie glauben gar
nicht wie oft ich die Frage in letzter
Zeit äh gestellt bekomme es es ist ja
auch berechtigt ähm dass dass man jetzt
so eine Art Performance Review macht ähm
also ich ich ich kann Ihnen empfehlen
ähm lesen Sie vielleicht noch mal was
ich in der NZZ in der neuen
zircherzeitung gesagt habe im Interview
vom 27 März ähm ich habe es auch noch
mal präzisiert im SRF Club der ist eine
Talkshow im Schweizer Fernsehen vom
13.06 und was ich die ganze Zeit
eigentlich versucht habe zu
argumentieren ist wann ist die
abnutzungsrate so hoch dass Russland
diese Kriegführung langfristig nicht
mehr durchhalten kann und äh ich habe
mich dann beschäftigt eben diese
abnutzungsrate zu schätzen äh kam auf
eine Rate von ungefähr fünf Panzern und
sechs gepanzerten
Infanterie Fahrzeugen pro Tag und habe
mir dann überlegt wie lange reicht das
bevor Russland ernsthafte logistische
Probleme bekommt und ich habe dann
folgendes gesagt ähm der Krieg ist für
Russland nach dieser abnutzungsrate
ungefähr diesem Zeitraum strategisch
verloren und ich habe die Lage
verglichen mit
1944 jetzt war das Problem ich habe das
allerdings etwas äh soll ich sagen etwas
doppeldeutig formuliert und das hat dann
manche Medien zu der Schlagzeile
gebracht ähm Wissenschaftler oder Dings
Dozent sagt
Ukraine hat im Oktober gewonnen und das
das ist natürlich eine mediale
Verkürzung dessen was ich gesagt habe
ähm und und dementsprechend ist das halt
so interpretiert worden dass ich gesagt
hätte im Oktober ist der Krieg aus ne
also die die beiden Sachen die sollte
man bitte unterscheiden und äh bevor man
mir hassms schickt äh dann möge man
bitte das Original Interview äh noch mal
lesen ja also so so verhält sich das und
ich bleibe bis heute be meiner
Einschätzung also wir wir sind jetzt
laut orix laut bestätigten Verlusten bei
etwa 2400 russischen Kampfpanzern
angekommen wie gesagt 600 fehlen noch
bis zur magischen Grenze von 3000 und
dann sollten wir uns die Lage noch mal
anschauen ich bleibe nach wie vor bei
meiner Einschätzung der Krieges für
Russland strategisch verloren russland
hat im Moment keine Möglichkeit mehr am
der gesamten Front die Initiative zu
gewinnen ihnen gelingen natürlich
Erfolge schon und sie haben auch gewisse
technologische Vorteile aber ähm damit
Sie wirklich ihr Ursprung Kriegsziel
erreichen also sprich Niederwerfung der
Ukraine regimewwechsel Angliederung an
das russische Imperium das wird nicht
mehr passieren selbst die russische
Elite spricht mittlerweile von aktiver
Verteidigung ich sage das auch gerne an
gruß an alle meine russlandtrolle wenn
Russland ja angeblich so großartig und
überlegen ist warum rollt die russische
Armee nicht einfach die Front auf ich
man wieso gräbt sie sich ein wieso wieso
errichtet sie befestigte Stellungen also
niemand der die Initiative hat macht
sowas denken sie Daal drüber danch aber
ähm die Frage ist dann natürlich wann
enden die Kampfhandlungen ne und da
möchte ich mich nicht zu irgendwelchen
Prognosen hin reißen lassen weil das
wäre wirklich komplett spekulativ es
geht nicht ums Ende der kampfwandlung ja
sondern es geht um die Abnutzung
wir haben noch einige Fragen die ich
Ihnen gerne weiterreichen möchte Herr
Kolb svenn odental fragt bei Facebook
wie sehr stellt sich die Ukraine auf
Engpässe beim Waffen Nachschub aus dem
Westen ein bislang ist die Ukraine ja
doch sehr stark drauf angewiesen
angesichts eines Fokus auf den
nostkonflikt oder anderen noch möglichen
Herausforderungen der NATO ja also Fokus
nach ostkonflikt sehe ich nicht ähm das
ist ist ein beliebtes russisches
propagandamotiv zu erzählen äh die die
USA könnten quasi nicht beide Staaten
gleichzeitig unterstützen mit
Waffenlieferungen oh doch können sie ähm
also wenn ich weiß nicht wenn sie wenn
sie von heute auf morgen zwei
Flugzeugträger Plus gleitflotte von 30
Schiffen äh ins Mittelmeer schicken
können äh doch doch also unterschätzen
Sie nicht die USA ne also deren
Rüstungsausgaben sind so groß wie die
der nächsten sieben folgenden Länder
zusammen undter schätzen sie nicht das
Central command
das sowohl im Persischen Golf wie auch
im Mittelmeer durchaus in der Lage ist
große Operationen zu führen also sie
müssen sich denken die hegen über dem
was das Central command an an Verfügung
hat im im gesamten nostraum ist das was
die USA für die Ukraine machen Peanuts
ja das sind nicht mal 5% des
US-amerikanischen Verteidigungsbudgets
das da reingeht sie müssen auch Bedenken
ähm die die Waffenlieferungen kann der
US-Präsident über die presidential
Drawdown authority selbstständig
initiieren dafür braucht er nicht den
Kongress im Kongress geht's um was
anderes da geht's um die supplementary
appropriation das heißt also
Finanzmittel aber die fließen nicht in
Form von Bargeld in die Ukraine wie
viele glauben die Fließen vor allem in
die amerikanische Rüstungsindustrie also
um dem Department of Defense und dem
militärisch industriellen Komplex in den
USA Aufträge zu geben um eben äh die die
Mittel die jetzt in die Ukraine
geschickt werden zu produzieren bzw die
Lager die sich jetzt Lehren wieder
aufzufüllen ein Beispiel habe ich vorhin
genannt glsdb ground Lou small diameter
bombs die von Boeing und SAB produziert
werden auch da geht jetzt eine neue
Produktionslinie los in den USA weil man
ganz bewusst gesagt hat wir wir bauen
diese Produktionslinie auf natürlich in
den USA um hier die langfristige
Versorgung zu sichern anderes Beispiel
wäre reheinmetall die sowohl in Spanien
als auch in Deutschland im Moment die
Produktion hochfahren auch in der
Ukraine gerade Joint Venture gegründet
hat haben damit die Ukraine
selbstständig Munition produzieren kann
also es es ist nicht so dass man in in
der Industrie das nicht gemerkt hätte
aber wir sind habe ich ja schon häufig
gesagt wie in jedem großen Krieg vor der
Situation bei Ausbruch des Krieges ist
das industriepotenzial darauf nicht
vorbereitet und typischerweise erreicht
das industriepotenzial eigentlich sein
Maximum dann wenn der Krieg sich schon
dem Ende zu neigt also wenn wir beim
Zweiten Weltkrieg schauen z.B da fing
man ja erst 1941 an wirklich die
Industrien massiv heraufzufahren und ihr
Produktion smaximum erreichten sie 1945
also in dem Jahr in dem der Krieg zu
Ende geht und das muss man natürlich
sehen dass dass ist langfristige
Verschiebung mhm zum Abschluss noch mal
der Blick auf die Gegenseite Sebastian
Gründler fragt wenn Russland Materialien
bzw Verstärkung aus Nordkorea bekommen
sollte wie würde die Ukraine darauf
reagierenm ja das können sie ja mal
durchrechnen also wir haben noch noch
keine bestätigten Bilder von der
nordkoreanischen munitionslieferung äh
die es die es angeblich gegeben hat aber
ähm wenn Sie jetzt denken man dieses
Schiff das Nordkorea angeblich geschickt
hat nach Russland enthielt ungefähr
500.000 Artilleriegranaten das ist
zumindest die die Schätzung der
Amerikaner so wenn sie jetzt sich
überlegen sie würden wieder wirklich
massiv die Initiative ergreifen nach
sowjetischche Doktrin also sie gehen
zurück zu einer feuerfrequenz von 50.000
pro Tag dann reicht ihnen das 10 Tage
wenn sie bei der jetzigen feuerfrequenz
bleiben von ungefähr 10.000 pro Tag dann
reicht das ihnen 50 Tage also das das
sieht nach viel aus ähm aber ähm die die
die der Konsum der Granaten ist so groß
dass ihnen so so vereinzelte punktuelle
Lieferungen äh nicht nicht reichen
sondern was sie wirklich tun müssten ist
eine leistungsfähige effiziente
eigenständige Rüstungsindustrie
aufzubauen und und das hat in Russland
nie so wirklich funktioniert die
russische Rüstungsindustrie ist zutiefst
korrupt ähm vieles von dem Geld was sie
da reinstecken versandet einfach und das
was ich bisher gesehen habe ähm bei den
schweren Systemen das beschränkt sich
hauptsächlich auf das wiederinstand
setetzen von alten sowjetischen System
also Russland zährt immer noch sehr von
dem mechanisierten Erbe der Sowjetunion
aber das geht in diesem Krieg so langsam
drauf das gleiche gilt bei den
artilleriesystemen und Granaten russland
hat mal angefangen mit dem Bestand von
etwa 17 Millionen Artilleriegranaten
davon sind 11 Millionen mittlerweile weg
und m irgendwann stellt sich für
Russland eben auch diese langfristig
industrielle Frage und da glaube ich
nicht dass das russische System dem
vereinigten westlichen System da noch
was entgegenzusetzen hat sagt Markus K
Herr K vielen Dank für die Zeit heute
Abend gerne schönen Abend noch danke
schön ja und auch danke an euch wieder
fürs einschalten und euer reges
Interesse an eure Fragen und Kommentare
Meinungen zu diesem Thema es beschäftigt
euch noch sehr das sehen wir hier auf
unserem Bildschirm deshalb werden wir
auch in den nächsten Wochen natürlich
weiterhin die Ukraine und den
ukrainekrieg im Blick behalten bis dahin
tschüss und auf
Wiedersehen
هها